And this child she's the only
one he'll communicate with
we need kong the world needs
him to stop what's coming
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's
out there and he's hurting people and
we don't know why there is something
provoking him that we're not seeing
the myths are real there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
godzilla versus kong trailer video they dropped
an alternate trailer with a bunch of different
footage so we'll break it all down it's kind of
like the godzilla versus kong super bowl trailer
even though it's like the japanese version of
the trailer thankfully they just released a
whole bunch of different footage during it
if you're new to the channel i will be doing
videos for the movie so be sure to subscribe to
get everything obviously it's coming march
26th on hbo max it'll also be coming to
theaters if theaters are open where you live so if
you really do want to see it on a big screen like
an imax you might have the opportunity to do that
just depends on where theaters are open around you
but some of the new details they revealed here in
addition to all the mechagodzilla stuff is that
we will learn more about the ancient war of the
monsters in the older battle between godzilla and
kong that they referenced during the trailer like
they say that there was a war for dominance and
they were the last two standing it's a reference
to the classic 1962 movie king kong vs godzilla i
know everybody's wondering because in the new
films he's just called kong they don't call
him king kong if after this movie he does wind up
defeating godzilla so they start calling him king
kong but they referenced the battle that they had
that's a reference to the events of the 1962 movie
there'll be a lot more easter eggs for it during
the movie as well like really important detail
here in their major hong kong fight around all
these neon lights in the buildings and the high
rises just make everything pop on screen a lot
more it makes it feel kind of like a video game
when godzilla unleashes his atomic breath on kong
pretty standard attack that's like his first go-to
special move kong shows some creative maneuvers
and blocks it with the axe that he's fashioned
out of the tree in one of godzilla's dorsal spikes
what is the best defense against one of godzilla's
special attacks a piece of godzilla himself
like everyone was making the batman v superman
movie references when the last trailer dropped
because they're fighting each other seemingly
before they team up to fight a greater threat in
mechagodzilla but right here with kong in the new
weapon it's kind of like attacking superman or
doomsday with other kryptonian weapons like what
is the only thing that can pierce superman's
skin because godzilla in the context of these
new monsterverse movies is almost invincible
even without his special attacks but here's
the thing though talking about more easter eggs
for the classic king kong vs godzilla 1962 movie
now i actually think that this weapon was made
using one of godzilla's dorsal spikes from the
original war that they're talking about during the
other trailer footage like when they talk about
the fight for dominance that they had a long time
ago godzilla fought kong there was a clear winner
king kong actually won the fight in the 1962 film
if you haven't seen that i'd recommend checking it
out before you see the new movie but during that
original fight kong damaged godzilla probably and
some dorsal spikes broke off of his back and then
kong used one of those later to make his weapon
we also got confirmation on some of the other
titans that we see during the trailer and what's
going on with them so what was originally the
nozuki like the giant flying snake titans on
skull island they're actually calling those war
bats in the new godzilla versus kong movie but
it's the same basic titan from the classic films
the other one in the separate fight is kamazotz
the bat titan the name literally translates to
death bat and he was the mayan bat god associated
with the night death and sacrifice as far as we
know they in mechagodzilla are the only brand
new titans debuting during the movie but we'll
see if any others show up i know a lot of you
are also wondering why kong is so big compared
to godzilla in the new movie too when he's not
supposed to be that big i'll explain why they kind
of explained a little bit during kong skull island
but it involves them weaving in a lot of mythology
from the classic movies explaining how those
movies can exist in the new movies timeline like
oh these are all things that happened in their
history and this is just the present day fights
that they're happening right now in the new movies
like they did the exact same thing during godzilla
king of the monsters weaving in the old film's
mythology where they explained that a long time
ago godzilla also fought a war of the monsters
with king ghidorah to beat him and that was their
way of weaving the classic 1964 movie which was
called ghidorah the three-headed monster into
the new movie canon the ending of that movie is
almost the exact same as the ending of godzilla
king of the monsters where godzilla teams up with
rodan and mothra to defeat godor except at the
end of the classic film ghidorah flies off in
defeat they don't kill him but that enabled the
new movie king of the monsters to just say that
that happened earlier in their timeline and now
godzilla has to kill him once and for all and
a lot of the story of godzilla vs kong flows from
the ending of godzilla king of monsters there's a
lot of big twists that are based on what happens
during that last movie but even though godzilla
and kong fought this war for dominance years and
years ago in that classic film they're both good
characters so in present day they're probably
not gonna kill each other as they say during
the trailer they're being manipulated to fight
by the evil apex organization which is kind of
like an evil version of monarch they don't reveal
too much about them during the trailer there's a
couple scenes like demon bashir's character here
seems like he might wind up being their leader
just because his scenes have this really ominous
tone about them and it seems like his character is
very powerful and important in the context of the
movie but apex are the ones that have seemingly
created mechagodzilla which has since been
confirmed as the real main villain of the movie
thus the batman v superman comparisons he'd be
like the doomsday of this scenario and because
they're doing so many references to the classic
movies there will be a lot of easter eggs for the
original mechagodzilla movie which is a separate
movie so they're incorporating a lot of elements
from a lot of the different classic films into
this new one like during the new movie godzilla
is supposed to have another new ability and during
the mechagodzilla classic film he had this special
magnetic breath designed to take advantage of the
fact that mechagodzilla was made entirely of metal
i don't know if that's going to be his special
new ability in the new film but it'll probably
have something to do with that something designed
to take advantage of mechagodzilla's weaknesses
the only bits of mechagodzilla we've actually
seen in the trailer so far confirmed are these
two scenes at least as far as we know this one
here with a metal looking head attacking everyone
at the beginning of the trailer then this later
scene of the apex scientist monitoring its systems
notice the outline on the screen behind them is a
very godzilla looking outline that says something
about systems charging because mechagodzilla
would be a giant robot that would run on
really really really big batteries but also a
lot of you long time godzilla movie fans have
also pointed out that some of the godzilla scenes
in the trailer could be deceptive when they claim
godzilla's been attacking cities randomly they
don't know why someone's making him do this it
could be one of a couple things it could be the
real godzilla trying to destroy apex space and
find mechagodzilla to kill it or it could be a
big easter egg for the classic mechagodzilla movie
in which mega godzilla was given this organic
looking disguise to make him look like the real
godzilla so he went around destroying everything
pretending to be the real godzilla so that people
would hate godzilla then during one of their
later fights godzilla tears the disguise off of
him revealing the metal body underneath like how
dare you impersonate me so some of the godzilla
scenes in this trailer could just be mechagodzilla
designed to look like real godzilla you do have to
wonder how long it took apex to build that because
that is one massive massive robot but the whole
idea this arc that they're weaving through all the
new movies is that apex has been harvesting dna
from the monsters and using it to create weapons
and other products to profit from they mentioned
that briefly when they were in the monarch base
in the last film and to fund his operations he
began trafficking in a new and dangerous market
titan dna what the hell someone going to do with
a giant warrant you kidding martinez what can't
you do with it pharmaceuticals bio weapons food
hell there isn't a country or a company on the
planet that doesn't want to get its hands on one
of these suckers and remember this is just a larva
that's a baby after a cocoons something else is
going to crawl out but supposedly apex uses dna in
parts of king ghidorah after the last big fight in
combination with other monsters in godzilla's dna
to create their abomination their mechagodzilla
so it's more than just a robot version of godzilla
in the new film it's like this monstrosity making
more doomsday batman v superman references taking
parts of kryptonian dna and mixing it with lex
luthor's human dna to create an abomination mega
godzilla is like their version of the abomination
and the other really cool thing if you're a big
fan of the lore of the monster verse that they
started weaving into the new films we're supposed
to learn more about the deeper mythology behind
the history of this version of the monster verse
remember the underwater temple that was godzilla's
home for thousands of years during the king of the
monsters they had all these easter eggs it seems
like they spent a lot of time developing this
ancient culture but then they blew it up with that
atomic bomb when they were trying to regenerate
godzilla's power like oh it would have been cool
to explore more that and learn more about that
temple but they did explain that this ancient
culture that predates all known civilizations
from thousands and thousands of years ago
worshipped the monsters as gods in not just
this particular temple these particular people
people all over the world worshipped all the
monsters as gods not just godzilla and kong
all the legends the stars they're true they
really were the first gods if only the earth
and stones could speak the stories they could
tell us but apparently in the new movie we're
supposed to learn more about these ancient people
this ancient culture like monarch will continue to
explore the lore behind that civilization the
way they explained during the last movie also
for people wondering why kong got so much bigger
we've learned a little bit more about this since
the last trailer came out apparently he's been
living closer to the source of the underground
radiation on skull island where all the skull
crawlers came from during the last movie
and you have to imagine that he's been alive for
a long long time so he just continued to grow
all these years since the last big war of
dominance so the events of the 1962 movie
are canon to the new movie it explains why he's so
much smaller in the classic film because he was a
lot younger and he just hadn't had time to grow
this big what will happen is there were a couple
other big super bowl trailer videos that dropped
i'll try to do videos for them there was also an
alternate falcon and winter soldier trailer
as well for the marvel stuff with alternate
footage so i'll do a video for that too leave
all your video requests in the comments below
you can click here for that brand new falcon
and winter soldier trailer i'll be doing episode
videos for that real soon and you can click
here for that brand new Wandavision episode 6
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!